[Musique]
le président du département cyrille
melchior rencontre patrick lebreton
maire de la commune de saint-joseph
ensemble ils signent le pacte de
solidarité territoriale le département
alloue une enveloppe de 3,2 millions
d'euros en investissement et de 600000
euros en fonctionnement dans le cadre de
ce dispositif des aides en faveur des
communes de la réunion les élus se sont
ensuite rendus sur le terrain pour
suivre le chantier d'aménagement de la
rue jean albany des travaux de liaison
qui seront en partie financées par le
pst c'est faire du social donc en faveur
des personnes les plus en difficulté
c'est aussi participer à l'aménagement
du territoire quand on aménage le
territoire on met en place des
équipements qui rendent service aussi
bien aux jeunes comme aux moins jeunes
mais aussi en dehors de l'activité dans
un département qui souffre d'un taux de
chômage élevé
ben là on soutient aussi l'activité
économique l'activité des entreprises et
d'une belle entreprise communal c'est
original à sa joseph les financements
apportés par le pacte de solidarité
territoriale permettront l'aménagement
d'équipements structurants et de
proximité sur la commune de saint joseph
ils soutiendront également la mise en
place d'actions sociales comme les cases
à nîmes puis à tous j'ai connaît un gros
mâle
c'est la solitude c'est contre ça qu'il
faut se battre et noé dans une démarche
aujourd'hui d'amener de l'animation à
domicile qui est là dessus on a
rencontré donc un acteur qui veut nous
aider parce que c'est sa mission
principale sa compétence à savoir le
conseil départemental avec le président
cyril michael r la visite se poursuit
par la pose de la première pierre de
cette future salle de réception pour le
troisième âge
le pst permet la mise en place de ces
actions de proximité en faveur des
réunionnais
la journée se termine dans la bonne
humeur par une danse sur un air de sega
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]